I'm extraordinarily concerned about our
trans friends and allies because I do
believe that they are at serious risk
like it's not an exaggeration I think
that there this is this is an overt
threat we are now seeing uh for for
several years now to be perfectly honest
I have pointed out to you that at events
like CPAC and others the biggest
Applause lines even at Trump rallies the
biggest Applause lines come during the
anti-trans moments of speeches when Ted
Cruz says my pronouns are kiss my ass
and everybody stands in cheers well I'm
Ted Cruz and my
[Music]
and Trump says we must not allow
teachers to teach transgender without
parental consult but no teachers should
ever be allowed to teach transgender to
our children without parental consult
this has been building for a while
and it's now open season